- Well, congratulations
on your engagement.
- Thank you.
- And the reason why I bring
it up as well is I asked him.
I was like, "Well, how did you propose?"
And I didn't know if you mind
but do you mind telling
everybody how it happened?
It was beautiful.
- No, we didn't, I had no idea, obviously.
I just was like,
in fact, we, I was trying
to get out of going
back to Oklahoma because it
was getting too complicated
with COVID and, the family and,
and I'm like, "I think we
should just cancel the trip."
You know, it was like one of those, like
and then we got it all
together and we ended up going.
And so his sister and her
family, they were there.
My kids were there.
And, my brother and his family.
We were all there, we
always are all there.
And we were gonna go see
we're building a house there.
So we were gonna go from
the one part of the land
to the other part of the
land to go see the house.
And meanwhile, I guess
Blake had had this ring
like ready to go for
like a couple of weeks.
And he had, nobody knew.
Like nobody knew, my dad
knew because on my birthday
he had showed my dad and
said he was gonna do it or whatever.
- Oh my God, he's so old fashioned.
He probably talked to your dad first.
- Well, I had my birthday party.
And it wasn't a party, it
was a birthday COVID moment
in the house when I turned,
whatever it was, I turned.
(laughter)
And,
- 29.
- And then anyways,
so we got there and everybody was like,
"No, we gotta get back.
We're cooking like a hobo stew on the fire
and we can't let it burn"
and my son was like,
"No, I gotta go to the
bathroom, I don't wanna go."
And like, it was like all
these things happening.
And, I walked in.
And my son was like sitting
right by this like fireplace
and Blake basically like was
getting down on his knees
to do a fire and he goes,
"Hey, can you look in
that cabinet over there
and get me a fire starter."
So I opened the cabinet and
there was like a ring in a box.
And I was like, "Oh!"
Like "What, are you serious?"
And then, so everybody
like, came running around.
'Cause I guess they heard
us screaming or whatever
and crying and,
so there was no video, it was just like
my sister-in-law to be was
just like shooting pictures.
And that's that photo that we put out, so
it was a pretty magical moment--
- It's kinda cool that it's not on video.
I mean, I know you might want it,
but at the same time,
I feel like our lives are always videoed
and always have--
- Kelly, it's not cool
that it's not on video.
No, I'm just kidding.
- But it was amazing.
And are you aware that your fiance now.
- This is so, I feel like I'm
having like a weird moment,
like, I'm on your show, we're
talking about my engagement.
Like, it's just like what?
- No, and here's the thing,
you're engaged, to this guy who was
a beautiful pageant queen or King.
(laughter)
(cross talking)
So a pageant King, you, this is your love.
Look at that.
Oh my God, he's so cute!
Oh my God, that's funny.
That's my nickname, Turbo.
He's wearing a turbo jacket.
That's so funny, I didn't know this.
- Really, I didn't know
that was your nickname.
- Well, my brother named me Turbo
because I never shut up and I talk a lot.
Well, it stick, it stuck, so.